aujourd'hui on va regarder pas moins de
douze astuces pour bien savoir utiliser
votre smartphone samsung avec one day 4
one day 4 est basé sur l'android 12 et
ça c'est bien parce que sur android 12
on a vu arriver matérial ue qui permet
de personnaliser pas mal de choses donc
c'est quand même d'avoir ici et bien
c'est quelle manière ça le soul travail
pour bien intégrer matériel you quelles
sont les nouveautés y en a douze que
j'ai sélectionné pour vous deux astuces
pour bien utiliser votre smartphone
samsung en 2022 et ça c'est vachement
cool et pour le faire on va utiliser est
bien le plus grand écran comme ça vous
verrez bien ce sera bien avec la caméra
qui planquaient jusque là et on va tous
regardés sur un samsung galaxy z paul ii
iii et on y va tout de suite
qu'on peut faire c'est personnalisés
personnalisez personnalisé par totalisé
c'est le credo d'android 12 avec
matériel lyon le retrouve également ici
alors pour revenir personnalisé on vient
ici dans les paramètres et là vous avez
fonds est-il d'écran non ça c'est cool à
savoir que déjà pouvez choisir votre
fonds alors on va se mettre un truc un
petit peu différent dans la vie j'aime
bien prendre une photo avec du rouge
voilà ça c'est au centre pompidou donc
on sait là on le met sur l'écran
d'accueil et verrouillage ok je mets sur
les deux je synchronise le tout et là je
vois quand va j'ai un truc est super
intéressant c'est ce qui s'appelle ray à
la palette de couleurs alors en fait
soit je laisse par défaut comme ça et
c'est un petit peu moins ou feint voyez
c'est qu'on a qui est très très très
standard et on s'en fiche un petit peu à
venir extraire des couleurs de ma photo
alors je tire plus son rouge donc je
peux me mettre ça et je peux même venir
à l'appliquer regardez c'est écrit juste
en bas ici je l'appliqué également aux
icônes comme ça au moins j'aurai tout
qui sera complètement optimisé
personnalisé ça sera vachement bien je
définis comme palette parler faut
regarder lorsque je viens ici alors déjà
j'ai ma photo c'est parce qu'être mieux
comme photo ne vous le cache pas mais je
retrouve toutes les couleurs qui sont
dans ma photo à savoir ce petit dégradé
de rouge que j'ai ici je les ai
également sur des icônes sur le côté et
ça c'est vachement bien aller je
retrouve ici la toute musicaux en rouge
mais voyez de la même manière si je vais
choisir un fond d'écran samsung genre
celui la taxe venir positionner la même
chose exactement par défaut sur mes deux
écrans et bien gardé j'ai ensuite une
palette de couleurs qui va être
complètement personnalisé et je trouve
ça vachement cool parce qu'en termes
d'expérience et quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup mieux donc ça c'est
vraiment toute l'intégration café ça me
sourit si au niveau de matériel ou
voyager mais icône bleue que je lui ai
retrouvé là la même dire là je veux dire
tout personnaliser et si vous avez plein
de produits de l'écosystème si vous avez
une droite si vous avez une tablette si
vous avez un ordinateur et bien vous
aurez one way également de la même
manière comme ça vous aurez une
personnalisation complète sur tous vos
appareils et ça c'est vachement bien
autre astuce c'est venir protéger ses
données sa vie privée vous venez ici
dans vos paramètres et dans vos
paramètres vous venez donc
confidentialité r&d la confidentialité
c'est juste ici vous cliquez là et là
vous allez venir voir pas mal de choses
vachement intéressante vous allez voir
déjà quelles sont les applications
autorisées sur les dernières 24 heures
donc là je vois par exemple j'ai mon
appareil photo le micro des contacts des
sms si besoin je viens dessus je vois à
quel moment lauréats récit et ça j'ai
vachement d'information dessus je sais
exactement ce qui s'est passé j'ai
également mon gestionnaire
d'autorisation qui situent juste la
voyez sur les activités physiques sur
l'agenda l'appareil photo un truc qui
est vachement sensible regardez par
exemple ici j'ai mon appareil photo de
votre plus cliquer dessus et lâche venir
évoquer les autorisations donc la gemmi
autorisé seulement si l'application est
en cours toujours demandé ne pas
autoriser et je peux très bien par
exemple ne pas autoriser si une
application tierce qui utilisent mes
photos mon micro et je veux pas être
embêté parce que ni résident décoché est
comme ça il n'aura jamais accès à mon
appareil photo à mon micro et serait
tranquille et ça c'est bien il ya un
autre truc à savoir c'est par exemple
regarder j'ouvre mon application en
photo à droite il vous affiche hop on
utilise ici le micro utilisé ici la
caméra soit c'est vachement cool et si
vous voulez savoir un moment bah tiens
je sais que j'ai une application qui
utilise mon micro et la caméra c'est là
qu'elle est bien au plat je viens dans
mon centre de contrôle est juste ici en
haut à droite pour trouver une icône je
clique dessus et comme ça je vois quelle
application utilise qu en ce moment
encore utilisation engagé l'appareil
photo encore utilisation samsung apps ex
service claque je clique c'est quoi ce
truc samsung apps et services qu'est-ce
qu'ils utilisent autorisé le stockage ok
je n'ai rien d'autre à dessus et la même
année a envoyé par exemple et vous
montrer la même chose pour mon
application d'enregistrement audio je
viens d'en samsung mon enregistreur
vocal ici je clique donc l'âge de la
petite icône verte qui s'allument ici et
de la même manière regard des jeux
cliquant ici et je vois que j'ai un
enregistrement encore utilisation par
l'enregistreur vocal trouve ça
extrêmement rassurant comme ça on sait
réellement ce qui aurait alors on va
arrêter l'enregistrement parce que ça
n'a strictement aucun intérêt mais si je
veux être tranquille et carrément
désactivé ma caméra ou désactiver au
micro parce que j'en ai pas besoin et
que je suis un peu inquiet eh bien
regardez je viens ici dans mon centre de
contrôle et alors il faut viendra
ajouter manuellement les est ici accès à
l'appareil photo accès au micro je
clique dessus et je peux venir
désactiver très facilement ça c'est cool
et c'est rassurant vous voyez vous avez
vraiment la main sur la confidentialité
vous voyez ce qui se passe pouvez
activer désactiver par application de
façon globale trouve ça vachement bien
entre nouveautés sur mon nuage 4.0 et
bien ce sont les widgets la gestion des
widgets où il y avait déjà des widgets
annoncé pas tout nouveau mais là on va
connaître et widgets avec des coins
arrondis de tous les côtés donc bon
c'est sympa s'est redessiné c'est plutôt
cool pour vient modifier facilement la
taille de vos widgets vous en voulez un
petit peu moins vous en voulez un petit
peu plus et pour venir installer le
widget vous appuyer là un appui long
vous cliquez sur widgets et là vous les
avez ils sont simples c'est très très
lisible donc si vous voulez installer
des widgets d'un vous en avait des
tonnes sur la météo sur maps sur la
maintenance en fonction bien évidemment
des différentes applications qui vont
être installées sur votre smartphone
bref les une gestion simple intuitive
pratique tout ça vraiment bien alors là
je vous ai fait un sommet du foot race
est pas terrible terrible mais avoue
d'optimiser votre smartphone comme vous
voulez en fonction de vos widgets elle
même le petit dinosaure ici donc je
trouve ça assez marrant est plutôt bien
fait une fois de plus sur manuel 4.0 une
autre astuce pour un usage qui est
extrêmement important c'est la prise de
photos d'art bas parce que tout le monde
prend des photos aujourd'hui et surtout
qu'à un des points hyper important et on
sait quelles photos sont très bonne sur
les smartphones de samsung et plus vous
allez monter en gamme et meilleures
seront vos photos mais on veut toujours
aller plus loin par exemple si vous
voyez dans le mode professionnel dont
vous allez voir un truc qui vachement
mais regardez on va y aller on va dans
plus et on va dans pro ici alors moi je
l'avais activer la grille il faut vous
activié la grille pour l'activer c'est
très facile vous allez dans vos
paramètres ici vous avez la grille vous
la cocher juste là et ensuite vous allez
avoir bien évidemment votre grille qui
vous donne votre cadre en fait vous avez
vos tiers mais en plus de ça c'est un
truc qui est vachement d'un milieu vous
avez votre niveau d'un pin et donc hélas
comme savourer si votre photo et droite
ou si elle n'est pas droite ça c'est
tout bête mais c'est vachement bien ça
pourra vous sauver la vie dans plusieurs
usages mais ça ne s'arrête pas là ils
ont été beaucoup plus loin bien
évidemment c'est que au lieu d'abord
vous savez les petits sapins qu'on avait
à voir les petits arbres ou bien vous
êtes sur un ultra grand-angle le grand
angle en fois de la compagnie bal à
cette fois ci ils ont fait un peu comme
tout le monde ils vous ont mis des
chiffres alors je trouve ça plutôt pas
mal vous voyez vous y repérer très
facilement vous savez où est ce que vous
êtes c'est pas une grande révolution
c'est juste rentrer un peu plus dans la
norme et si ça fonctionne très bien
autre astuce cette fois-ci vous êtes sur
votre écran d'accueil et vous voulez
avoir accès à des widgets rapidement
bien vous venez tapez ici deux fois et
vous avez des widgets qui vous donne
quelques informations essentielles alors
là moi ici et j'ai mis mon temps d'écran
bon j'ai pas la musique en écoute je
vais avoir ma météo vont à l'extrait de
l'agenda je peux venir enregistrer j'ai
des petits paramètres pour venir les
organiser très très facilement voyez je
peux venir à cocher bien-être numérique
la musique la météo le programme du jour
la prochaine alarme les dix bureaux en
chine l'enregistreur vocal et à prévenir
les réorganiser les déplacés lequel je
veux mettre en priorité et compagnie
donc tout ça assez cool plutôt bien fait
et dans l'idée pourquoi pas puisque je
vous parle de la zone 10 paix il ya un
truc qui va choix intéressant il faut
retourner dans ses paramètres à
l'intérieur de son smartphone vous allez
dans écran de verrouillage et vous avez
lol ouais zone displaced qui s'affichent
en permanence sur votre écran et
prévenir le programme est appuyé pour
afficher pendant 10 secondes affichage
permanent ou affichage selon un
programme et ça c'est plutôt pas mal
vous allez pouvoir bien le programme est
par exemple je viens dans l'oise un
display qui va être de 7 heures du matin
jusqu'à 18 heures et j'en ai pas besoin
le reste du temps ou alors je peux
uniquement affiché pour les nouvelles
notifications donc bon dans l'idée
pourquoi pas permis d'aller plus loin
avoir bien évidemment ça peut coller à
vous usa autre astuce et pour savoir où
est-ce que vous en êtes au niveau de la
santé de votre smartphone et bien
regardez vous venez paris si vous allez
dans batterie et maintenance de
l'appareil alors la voyez petite
vérification tout va bien j'ai un petit
smiley ça me rassure ok je vois que des
informations sur ma batterie des
informations sur mon stockage la mémoire
la protection de l'appareil qui
désactive et c'est pas bien ça mise à
jour logicielle diagnostic et voyez je
peux venir l'optimiser maintenant alors
si je clique dessus et hop là ça vient
d'optimiser mon appareil et ça va très
très rapidement et ça y est c'est fait
voilà terminé je mangeais un petit
diagnostic ici donc là je vois quelques
informations son état de la batterie le
nfc voir ce qui fonctionne ce qui va ce
qui va pas bon je vous passe très
rapidement et puis lorsque vous cliquez
regarder juste en haut ici vous avez
votre rapport de maintenance votre
historique de redémarrage à propos du
chargement température regarder le
rechargement fonctionne de manière
optimale entre dix et quinze mois vous
avez des petites informations qui sont
plutôt pas mal bien activée si la
production de l'appareil ce que je n'ai
pas fait mais qu'il va falloir finir
faire et voyez ici on passe d'excellents
à super tout va bien et après vous êtes
autres informations notamment sur la
batterie de votre smartphone en garde et
voyez où est-ce que vous en êtes le
temps restant disponibles utilisation
lors de la dernière charge et puis je
peux aller plus loin au niveau de
l'économie d'énergie mais j'ai d'autres
paramètres de batteries qui sont quand
même plutôt pas mal pour garder
protection de la batterie pour prolonger
la durée de vie de votre batterie
limiter la charge maximale à 85% sa
bride à 85% s'arrête ça vient protéger
vos cellules et ça évite de venir abîmer
votre batterie donc c'est plutôt pas mal
autre astuce qui pas mal c'est une
optimisation au niveau du clavier de
votre smartphone avec clavier samsung
vous venez dans votre application
message regardez là par exemple vous
venez ici juste on va vous le voyez vous
cliquez sur voter moggi enfin son veau
emoji vous connaissez ya un bien nouveau
mais vous avez on peut aussi une
association des bogies pour venir
optimiser votre humeur vous dire j'en
sais rien qu'est ce qu'on va voir là on
va voir suis là par exemple têtes qui
explosent or vous cliquez dessus on fait
un appui là alors voyez pas votre cas si
c'est une tête il nous parle donc à vous
venez vraiment associer différents
imoges permet vraiment de montrer votre
humeur je trouve ça assez rigolo on a
quoi on a des petits coeurs on a des
têtes qui explosent on a des bisous
piscine donc tirer bref ya plusieurs
petits emoji qui viennent se mettre
ensemble et moi je trouve ça vachement
marrant si vous voulez partager encore
plus l'humeur que vous avez malades et
là vous l'avez c'est marrant tous assez
rigolo c'est efficace sont bons ils et
pourquoi pas vous avez des tonnes de
stickers ya plein de choses iraient plus
en plus de stickers donc ça c'est plutôt
pas mal la collection se rallongent donc
si vous êtes fan des stickers il vous
souhaitez communiquer un max de choses
eh bien regardez là vous avez vraiment
vraiment de quoi faire donc ça c'est
quand même vachement bien on va
retourner faire un petit tour du côté de
la photo dans votre application photo
qui situent juste là si par exemple vous
voulez prendre une photo et mais que
c'est un peu sombre regarder on va venir
cacher la caméra et bien il vous propose
d'utiliser directement le mode nuit ça
c'est vachement bien je clique dessus ça
vient mais optimise et pour les pauses
un peu plus longue et ça sera
relativement cool petite astuce sympa
vous ouvrez votre application et au lieu
de faire une photo voulait faire une
vidéo directement mais au lieu de
cliquer sur vidéo lala et ensuite
d'appuyer versailles plus vite et bien
vous faites un appui long depuis photos
cliquez là ça lance une vidéo tu as
gardé vous passer ici là vous le voyez
vous à hellikon verrouillé et ça vous
enregistre une vidéo directement non ça
c'est vachement bien c'est rapide c'est
un petit raccourci mais c'est très
pratique astuce qui est vachement bien
vous avez fait une faute en mode
portrait vous allez pouvoir venir
l'éditeur garde et on va se prendre
cette photo là bas ma tronche il va
devenir embarras décès écrit juste en
dessous ici modifier l'effet d'arrière
plan donc on clique la avoir différentes
petites options alors là j'ai mon flou
bien évidemment je peux me régler
l'intensité du flou plus floue un flou
et compagnie ok je vais avoir à regarder
à côté un mode studio je vais avoir un
mode élevé ok mono mono elle devait
perdre en mono élevé mono faible j'ai
réglé ensuite l'intensité de
l'arrière-plan le fait disparaître un
peu pas du tout quoi comment why not et
même la luminosité sont ma tête et si la
wii sur le côté plus lumineux moins
lumineux pour ça colle vraiment à mon
arrière pense ça vraiment pas mal alors
la regarder l'intensité aussi c'est
marrant ce petit truc un peu rose points
de couleur ça me garde un peu une petite
lumière ici tout le reste est en noir et
blanc les grands cercles le tourbillon
la simply carrément la gerbe mais je
trouve ça marrant c'est plutôt efficace
et c'est sympa moi ce que je préférais
choix c'est celui là c'est le mono
faible avec l'intensité sur mon visage
là comme ça là c'est vachement cool
autre astuce dans la partie photo vous
connaissez probablement le mode single
take on retrouve exclusivement sur vos
smartphones de samsung qui est situé
juste là vous cliquez dessus ça vous
faire plusieurs enregistrements photos
vidéos tout en même temps sur une
période de quinze secondes et regardait
ce qui est vachement bien ici c'est que
votre single take vous le lancez donc là
ça vous faire peur d'enregistrement ça
vous met le départ de 15 secondes et ça
vous dit hey tu veux pas ça le second de
plus je clique dessus et ça me rallonge
de 5 secondes donc ça c'est vachement
bien où je peux passer d'un mode single
take de 15 secondes à 20 secondes très
facilement et ça c'est cool et d'autres
astuces que je trouve vachement bien
dans l'application galerie on va se
prendre n'importe quelle photo alarie
photos un peu sympa peut-être que vous
allez reconnaître très facilement et
dans la cour carrée du louvre ici on
peut venir avoir toutes les informations
les regarder ce qui est vachement bien
c'est que vous venez ici j'ai voulu
retrouver par position donc la regardait
là on se balade dans paris je vois mes
photos je vois ce que je veux donc là je
vois qu'à cet endroit là j'ai cinq
photos je clique dessus et je vais
retrouver les photos ici en bas donc ça
c'est vachement bien je vois que j'ai
des photos ici donc lâcher plus on était
en terrasse on buvait un coup donc l'âge
et les photos là je vois que j'ai des
photos là bref ça permet vraiment de
géolocaliser les photos de voir où elle
j'étais chaud ça vachement cool et
autres astuces également toujours dans
vos photos vous allez pouvoir venir
éditer vos métadatas vous cliquez dessus
la voyez sur cette photo a été prise au
cap quai françois mitterrand dans le
premier on joue également la date
d'ombré c'était métadatas un petit peu
standard cliquer sur modifier et la
regarde et je peux venir supprimer
l'adresse si je le souhaite si je pars
axa reste dans mes métadatas je peux
également de la même manière venir
modifier la date n'a été prise le 7 août
2021 si je veux la mettre j'en sais rien
moi au mode julien je peux le faire très
facilement donc ça c'est vachement bien
si vous voulez pas que vos photos garde
des datas des métadatas lorsque vous
avez notamment milliards et partagée
pour dire les supprimer les éditer très
facilement ça c'est bien voilà pour ces
quelques astuces sur moi nuage 4.0 on
voit qu'ici ça me saoule se base sur
android 12 la personnalisation qui a pas
une petite option que je trouve
vachement bien déjà il y avait un très
beau boulot de fait l'année dernière on
m'a dit avec trois points en jeu vous
l'avait présenté en vidéo cette
intégration 600 voix nue à 4.0 est
vachement intéressante à vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez quoi vous la
trouvez intégration plutôt bien fait
intéressante est ce que vous avez un
smartphone de samsung est ce que vous
allez en avoir peut-être que ça pourra
vous donner envie d'en avoir un en tout
cas ici on va lui ont déjà été déployés
sur les s-21 toute la gamme s 21 est
folle de trois aides flip 3 et puis plus
ça va aller plus bas y en avoir on va
arriver dans la gamme à il va y avoir un
déploiement tout au long de l'année donc
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle sur ce je
vous embrasse vous rendez vous très
bientôt pour continuer à parler tech
pour les soins de vous des mises au
chaos